it is interesting seeing you with hair
who would have thought you had so much
of it I I was hoping that my hair would
eventually grow I wouldn't that be sort
of like you you shave your head for
seven years and then you're bald and
your hair and I used to worry but what
was your time what was it like on there
were you nervous at all coming on cuz
this was like one of your first big
things right oh my God it was the first
thing I ever did that actually aired not
only that an said whatever we were on
the first day on set I had to be in a
pasty pasties and a th oh my boy walk
through the woods in Vancouver and I
want to say it was like October or
November it was freaking cold but I was
also like hey crew here's me naked
including you know Tom who had to open
the door and like literally was looking
anywhere but at me yeah he was so
uncomfortable yeah